so we'll just jump right in Bethany
thank you for joining us we're calling
these our quarantine Diaries or
quarantine confessional okay I want to
get into all the stuff you're doing with
be strong and with the great empowerment
mission but first where are you holding
up
is this the Hamptons house this is my
house in Long Island yes okay and you're
there with Brynn I was here with Brynn
and she unfortunately had to go back to
New York City which was very upsetting
for me but I am getting through it you
got big in smalls I just saw one pop up
in smalls and Brynn and I were here for
a week doing dances and cooking and I
had a home school going and arts and
crafts and snuggling with our babies and
relief work so we've been we've had a
structure yeah I saw you put out the
full like my note to parents create a
structure for the day make sure you have
a schedule yeah I guess what is your
note to everyone as we're dealing with
this like what are the takeaways here
the takeaways arts you really take deep
breaths and try not to live in the
anxiety because it's we're feeding on
each other's anxieties and it's hard to
problem-solve I've just known this from
business when I'm in the problem versus
relaxing and breathing and stepping away
for a second it's hard to be part of the
solution so that's very easier said than
done but people have to take a minute
and try to find the solution obviously
there's all the ways that people have to
keep clean and sanitized but I as I go
through my daily routine I think of
other ways you know putting your fingers
and moisturizers or not cleaning makeup
brushes or just not cleaning out your
hairbrush just there are many ways for
viruses to attack the system and so I'm
just thinking of you know hydration we
have hydration kits that are part of our
corona kits and I'm thinking about
hydration it flushes out toxins I hear
that this doesn't live in heat it could
be a myth but I know that hot detox salt
baths
are very very therapeutic and there
still is epsom salts at the market so
I'm taking hot baths just like there are
very logical things to do for whatever
business you're in to sit back and try
to think about how to find future
solutions I have my staff not paralyzed
but they're all at home and thinking
about how to help doing relief work and
thinking about how to be organized and
think about things that we haven't been
able to get to business-wise for a while
I'm a good leader and executor and
organized and I actually am good in a
crisis so you just have to sort of
collect yourself and it's hard with
parents who have kids at home and are on
top of each other and on top of their
spouses so find your own separate time
do a puzzle read I'm doing dances with
my daughter like we're learning
different dances together and talking
about music and doing breathing
exercises together so you really have to
find your yes
I mean you once famously said get a
hobby so we're all learning that right
people are getting hobbies before
playing chess people are meditating and
I think this is a global reset I think
we will all change from this I think
this is a shift from what I find is in
such a degradation in superficiality we
are just have become such a
self-involved gross self-important
superficial society I have been on
reality television I have been part of
that machine I have never really loved
social media
I have always done it because it's been
a part of my business and you sort of
has to be part of it if you're going to
move forward and I've always just felt
that it was counterintuitive to be
taking pictures of it-- how good I look
and filtering yourself and and bragging
about everything you're doing and what
you have and it just feels
counterintuitive and I always feel more
safe and comfortable when I'm using
social media to connect with other
people and use it as a network to find
people who are in hospitals that need
masks and people who are at home who are
suffering and people in big corporations
that want to help donate and help other
people and you know I want to be part of
the solution so yeah and this definitely
is this is a crisis
tell me about the corona kit you're
making with me strong in the global
empowerment mission and how can people
help what's needed all that kind of
stuff
the be strong is an initiative that
specializes in disaster relief when it's
actually a crisis when people have been
devastated people have nothing when
people are panicking when people just
want to connect with each other when
they want to help and that's where we
come in and stay long after the
headlines fade we just had a truck go to
Tennessee and 18-wheeler filled with aid
because of the tornadoes we are still
building schools and homes in the
Bahamas long after Dorian has swept
through and destroyed a lot of the
Bahamas 100 and something islands in the
Bahamas we have just finished another
initiative in Puerto Rico because
they've had earthquakes to add insult to
injury after their hurricanes we just
two weeks ago finished our second
mission in Australia ask for the fire so
we have longevity and we stay we have
distributed over 25 million dollars in
aid and relief globally Guatemala Mexico
you name it North Carolina California
fires and now we are working on the be
strong multi tiered approach one is
Corona kits which have hydration systems
in them immune building systems in them
San hand sanitizer gel which is being
manufactured directly for us
typically for us right now at a facility
we have a warehouse full of aid we are
now working with hospitals and
individuals nationwide who want to help
and who are passionate about their
hospitals Megan McCain asked how she can
help
I said you're from Arizona put us in
touch with who you want to help at what
hospitals Maria Menounos is from Boston
my boyfriend and I have a place in
Boston and I went to college at Boston
we're working on Mass General
Master Mass General Maria Menounos is
working on Cedar sinai and UCLA and it
does take a village and we are little
you know links in the chain and so we're
raising money for these strong cash
cards which go to people who are
underprivileged impoverished desperate
home waiting for help feel
panicked kids are home they can't afford
it they have no job no income and um you
know we need money I mean whatever but I
can't wait for the money to order masks
and sanitization
so I'm ordering it I'm paying for it and
you know we need to raise millions
millions of dollars this is a massive
massive effort and we don't have red
tape we can be Road we have such little
overhead a hundred percent goes to the
mission we have volunteers they're all
they're all yoga teachers school
teachers haired stylists the poor and
middle class are who run and move this
effort it's not the wealthy it's not
celebrities it's not the people that
talk the most on social media its
regular people that move this effort and
so we need a lot of money and we need to
keep spreading the message and we need
to keep taking in money because this is
a this is not just poor Rico or Bahamas
this is the world and we're trying to
help people all over the country and
make a real difference and make a real
dent in this thing so if people are able
to donate it's bethany comm slash be
strong yes and if bethany dot-com slash
should be strong be e th e n NY calm
slash be strong and something that's Pat
they're passionate about they can write
a note and say I want to donate massive
fast littles I'm I want to donate to the
kits or to people who need the cash
parts but a freedom and dignity by what
they want so I would also another
message I would say to stop hoarding
people are panic that they can't get
toilet paper you have what you need it
will be there we all help each other we
live in a society where we help each
other and let some other people get to
the store and buy what they might really
actually need I'm not going to the store
because I have enough pasta and ramen
too you know last me at least a month so
that's what I'm living on I love and all
this you've also been calling out the
billionaires on social media you've
gotten some traction there well I've
gotten traction in the press with the
billionaires I don't I mean I'm sure
that they're reading my messages because
people are calling them out and listen I
don't think the billionaires don't have
their own causes and don't donate and
aren't
talking to the white house and aren't
doing something but I know that I'm not
waiting for any red tape or anybody in
Nepal political world to tell me what to
do so if any of the 607 billionaires
want to hand us ten million dollars
trust and believe it can go immediately
into health care workers into poor
people's hands immediately I don't have
to wait to talk to anybody at the White
House to help people so I've called out
Jack Dorsey I've called out Mike
Bloomberg I'm calling out Elon Musk I'm
calling out Richard Branson I'm calling
out all of the billionaires in 607
billionaires in this country that this
would be a parking ticket for them I
think it would be less than a parking
ticket this would be 0.001 percent of a
person who has 1 billion dollars some of
these people have 50 billion 100 billion
and not in their companies I'm not
looking for them to do things for their
companies I'm looking for them to get in
their own pockets while they've lost 10%
of their net worth in the market and say
this is a global humanitarian crisis and
here's ten million dollars all right I
love them out call them I you know you
hate to see times of crisis like this
but I love watching you jump into this
mode because it is a very cool thing to
see that you've taken this platform that
you grew on your own and turn it into
now a global mission thank you global
mission and call them out I'm not afraid
they come to my front door
hand me a check I'm right here I'll show
them exactly where it's going a hundred
percent of it will go and I'm putting my
money where my mouth now it is because
my money is already going to the mast
and a hand sanitizer right now that's
where I've got to write these checks
because we as the former director of
FEMA said former head of FEMA he said we
can't wait to get the money we have to
pay for these things and figure it out
later so I'm paying for these things and
figuring it out later all right I have
some rapid fire how are you surviving
quarantine questions now great what are
you snacking on what's the go to in your
pantry
um I'm snack I don't know why for some
reason Korona has made me by fudgesicles
I was never a person who likes
fudgesicles I don't know why I there
were so many fudgesicles it was
steak but there was tons of ice cream
and I don't think people have their
priorities straight because ice cream is
much more important to me than steak by
every stretch on I'm missing salty
snacks in my house that's what might
were my shortages and I refuse to go out
to the store and take away from anybody
else but I'm missing superficial salty
snacks and I have we made quesadillas I
am more like cooking things to take a
little longer like Faro is an ancient
grain I've had Faro in my in my cabinet
for so long and I was wondering when I
was gonna make it well yesterday was
that day and we have hands a refried
beans so I'm making different Mexican
dishes I'm making I'm using truffle oil
because I have it and making truffle
pasta for my daughter so it's funny the
people that I know are more structured
with their meals and we're not snacking
that much my best friend is snacking ad
nauseam and she can't stop but eat all
your perishables first so I don't even
want salad but I have it in our fuse to
waste food I'm eating my salad my
avocado my tomato that was from last
week I'm eating all my perishables first
and frozen vegetables I've always been a
fan of frozen vegetables because if you
get back home from somewhere and you've
been away and you don't have time to go
to the market I always will get my
daughter frozen organic broccoli so I
have frozen zucchini noodles and
cauliflower rice and like I'll move on
to the frozen next and pastas that have
vegetables built in let me know that
existed I went to the market and no one
was buying that there were pasta bags
and it says there zucchini and
vegetables baked somehow mixed into the
veg the pasta god knows how they did its
magic but I'm making that I'm doing
anything that has vegetables mixed in
for my daughter and myself all right
what is the go to quarantine outfit are
you getting dressed every day is it a
pajama situation it started as a pajama
situation it moved into clothes Amoz
which were clothes and pajamas so it
would be a sweatshirt and pajama pants
and now I've moved into very very loungy
clothes at home I'm wearing Skinnygirl
jeans which are super comfortable
they're like where they're like pajama
jeans frankly sorry they're like pajama
jeans frankly the Skinnygirl jeans are
just so stretchy so I'm wearing
Skinnygirl jeans
it's a sweater but it feels and looks
like a robe so it's still sort of a
hybrid clothes Amoz but it's it's it's
it's involved but I'm still wearing my
men's clippers at all times okay
this process shoes are not a part of my
journey as Alexis on shits Creek says
okay not part of my journey right now
shoes are not part of my journey unless
I have to go outside or to the basement
where is Paul in all this Paul is in
Boston and I debated going to him last
night but I feel and I've told all my
friend and given the advice based on
lockdowns and being your kids we need to
be at home where we feel the safest and
the most comfortable anxieties are at a
height and we I need to do my own
routine and I need to be closest to my
child and I need to have my backyard and
my dogs and my my things I can touch and
I just and he's working on helping me
with Mass General and Boston efforts and
what's interesting is we're not together
but this has brought us closer than ever
like it's just you few closer to the
people that you can't be with you're
feeling like you want to talk to them
and FaceTime them and you miss them and
so we are closer than ever but I want to
go there I just we're both sort of
panicked if I go and I can't leave and
it's not rational because I'm sure I'd
be able to leave but I just you know you
want to just feel in your safe place at
the moment yeah I mean lucky to be with
a big backyard and not be in the Back
Bay of Boston and have the ocean nearby
with nobody added just to breathe the
air and feel one with God in the
universe and you know make this a
spiritual time which I'm doing yeah
alright what are you binging what are
you catching up on TV wise while you're
stuck inside though shits Creek has been
a big one and peaky blinders I've gotten
back into that because I'm finding that
if you watch something deeper you can
get connected to it and if you watch
something superficial you sort of get
like fidgety and like you know agitated
you have to I'm not watching superficial
crap TV right now I have to say I'm
watching things that are meaningful I'm
not interested in watching people with
you know fake eyelashes and
you know expensive handbags right now
I'm not here for that I'm not here for
like arguing and stress I'm here for
laughter and depth and mystery and
intensity that sounds like maybe a show
you used to be on what you're talking
about which I know a lot of people are
binging those shows right now
yeah I'm not binging um the I'm not
binging reality TV because it feels like
junk food it doesn't feel getting me
anxiety
so like I said I'm binging humor
scripted humor and intense television
with like real strong plot lines so I
can invest versus feeling gross I'm not
watching things that make me feel gross
yeah we are getting a new season of
Housewives soon it's the one you are not
a part of how does it feel now having
stepped back not being on that I feel
very separated from housewives it did
take a minute to feel that it didn't
really have anything to do with me
anymore and it doesn't reflect or
represent where I am in my life and I
it's just like that song it's somebody
that I used to know so you know that
feels that feels good rather than being
loving it hating it being so passionate
about it I just it's really just some
somebody somebody that I used to know so
I'm happy for them and I wish them all
the success in the world but I'm really
happy with where I am in my relationship
in my relationship my daughter and in my
work in my work with Mark Burnett and
MGM we have sold multiple television
shows and but I'm most importantly
invested in be strong and doing relief
work and it feels like a real contrast
to shooting reality TV so I'm glad that
I took step back and I'm focusing on
what's really important to me well I'm
excited though for your return to
reality TV I'm excited for the big shot
whenever we can get that up and running
after this is this I must sure I'm sure
this is affecting the production on that
right this is sort of affecting the
production but we are all everyone's at
home preparing for it and we're ready to
start casting I'm just
ready to post about that yet because I
just don't think that it's the
appropriate time to be marketing people
coming into New York for this job
I just doesn't feel correct at this
moment but we are ready to start casting
we are preparing the real-life projects
that these people will be working on
which are connected to my real life
business and this coronavirus relates to
that because it's gonna have it have an
effect on certain parts of my business
and what I'm doing so we're working on
that there's another show that we are in
the process we're in contract stage with
uh that I'm producing and might just
sort of sprinkle myself in and then
another show sort of about I don't think
I can get in detail about it but another
show that we've sold so we've sold three
shows and Counting and we're ready to be
up and running second weekend so MGM is
a powerhouse Mark Burnett is a total
gangster when it comes to TV production
and we're really teed up for it so I'm
excited alright until then is there any
episode of your old shows that you
recommend people watching who need a
bethenny fix like one set of episodes
it's like go back check those out if you
need me in the meantime I'm not
directing people towards that kind of
like really really instead yeah I'm well
I'm not I just honestly don't feel like
I want to direct people towards conflict
between women at this time it's just not
where I am makes total sense to me
alright anything else we need to know
anything else you want to share before
we now just hug your babies wash your
makeup brushes clean your dogs take hot
baths drink ginger if you have it
drink tea to calm your nerves green
vegetables if you have them are
detoxifying fruits if you have them are
detoxify pump the water liquids the
vitamin C keep your keep your program
going give your kids than math tables
set aside an hour to you do some
stretching let your kids do their
homework like be structured in some way
take a shower have them do the same to
feel a routine to feel clean have you
tight because structure is very helpful
all right don't get side into the bad
news don't get sucked into the bad news
that's I think the number one takeaway
here you get sucked and you start
watching the news you're panic-stricken
don't get sucked in dip in to know
what's going on dip out but it's a whole
it's a rabbit hole and dip and by the
way read a book read nicked do art do a
project please clean your closets out
people will need your clothes you know
just do things that are constructive I
went into my basement should try to
start organizing my basement
you know organize organize it gets your
mind off things it's a great thing to do
go through your kids clothes there's so
many closing that they don't wear
they're too small you know just just be
Buddhist about it this is a global reset
so be part of the change in your own way
[Music]